ja ich bin hier der pole 96 infrage
wie dann hast du sollen so einem album
gearbeitet ist schwer oder
auch leicht macht sich bars oder nicht
na ja
danke und
ja an dem album habe ich schon eine
ganze zeit gearbeitet
im tonstudio
direkt wird über über ein monats dran
gesessen und sonst manche manche lieder
hatte ich da hatte ich vorher schon ein
paar ideen zu und dann hinterher gibt es
eben auch nach den nachdem das ganze
abgeschlossen ist mit dem studio
arbeiten noch layout sachen die gemacht
werden müssen dass man hier gerne noch
irgendwie ein paar zeichnungen einsetzen
möchte ins booklet und solche
geschichten also da ist man schon einige
monate mit beschäftigt mit dem
gesamtpaket